[Music]
you
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and welcome to I
guess it's our third or fourth sort of
debate most of you are familiar with the
introduction cards so I don't have to
say much about the speakers on the back
is where you participate right very
legible versions of what question you
might have because Kevin Kelley will be
up here looking at the questions and
trying to read them in the dark he'll
pass the good ones up to me and I'll hit
these guys with some of the best well I
was at Stanford 50 years ago in the
biology department we did not have a
department of violent engineering and it
would have been unimaginable even though
molecular biology was just getting
cranked up at that point this is a
technology that's growing about as fast
as microbes do that is more with greater
exponential speed and information
technology has we're now at the point
similar to when micro computers began to
replace the mainframes in the mini
computers and the making of the
technology left the universities and the
government labs and went into garages so
we're now getting garage biotechnology
and one is soon as well
what does that mean there must be some
good news and some bad news in that and
how do we tell the difference tonight
we'll use our debate format which is
doesn't have winners and losers it has
probers in both directions previously
we've asked the audience to suggest who
goes first but tonight we really needed
a grounding at what synthetic biology is
so we're gonna ask drew endy to go first
and the format is he speaks and show
slides for 15 minutes then the three of
us sit down up here and Jim Thomas
interviews drew to draw out more
background filled data all the stuff a
good interviewer does and to show that
he's paying attention when he finishes
that 10 minute interview he has to
summarize Drew's argument to drew
satisfaction where drew says that's it
you got it
then they reverse roles and Jim Thomas
from the etcetera group comes up and
does his 15 minutes and then sits down
and his probe for 10 minutes by Drew and
the drew has to give his position to the
point that Jim agrees that's right we
got it
and then we're into more freeform
interaction your questions and so on
let's start with Drew endy so my remarks
will start with what I want to do second
why I want to do it third what's
happening with respect to the wet
technology some of the issues that come
up a proposal and that'll be it
what I want to do I'd like to develop
tools that make biology easy to engineer
by biology I mean the stuff of life so
little bacteria that swim around make
chemicals perhaps someday go into your
body and fix stuff up I also mean the
stuff of life like this larger objects
mammals what have you bring them back
change them and then once we get all
that working maybe other things too
although that might be on more than 10
or 20 years from now so spaceships that
self-assemble ecosystems or Trey
Parker's poly gluteal monkeys
in other words how do we take this
material the one part of nature for
which Engineering has Stewart mentioned
has not really yet been well developed
and turned it into an engineer able
substrate such that wherever possible to
make gigantic programmable gourds that
differentiate into four bedroom two bath
houses we could do that these are ideas
obviously and it's not clear that the
substrate of biology is a physical
material chemical material will support
all of this but one can imagine what do
I want to do part two tools that enable
humanity seems to be irresponsible to
set out to rebuild the living world if
it were without also understanding who
we are and what we intend to do with
that capability so for example tools
that support conversation this is slide
of a website from Paul Robin house group
at Berkeley trying to bring people
together to talk about some of the
issues with making biology easier to
engineer tools that enable the sharing
of wisdom so if we have tens of
thousands of years with biology as a
tool for us as a source of food how do
we take advantage of that or at least
continue to recognize and celebrate that
tools for building a community so if
this is a photograph of students from
Lincoln High School here in San
Francisco working at UCSF I was a
teenage genetic engineer last summer
they say is that good or bad and how do
we give these students a future that
they can build for themselves where they
can take responsibility for the direct
manipulation of genetic material tools
for safety if this is the subway news
paper from 30 years ago in Boston where
they were publishing recipes for how to
clone a toxin in your kitchen is that a
good or bad thing to do how come people
didn't come forward doing this or did
they kill themselves trying so we didn't
hear about them tools for security if
this is a publicly accessible sequence
for a genome that happens to encode
hemorrhagic fever like Ebola and you
could each download it from the internet
and purchase the DNA encoding it for
20,000 dollars do we secure a world
based on biology in which that's
possible or not tools that enable beauty
beauty both human
instructed and inspired by what we see
in nature so those are two things that
I'm arguing for tools that make biology
easier to engineer and tools that enable
humanity why do I want to do this one to
understand you can take apart a car in
order to understand the car and that
gives you some sort of understanding but
then if you take the pieces as they're
scattered about your driveway and
attempt to put them back together you
might have a couple pieces left over
you'll have a aha moment when you turn
the key and it might work or it might
not
basically in biology in its modern era
over the last seventy years we've
inherited a reductionist approach driven
by physicists starting around 1930 and
this became molecular biology and
genetics we've gotten really really good
at taking natural biological systems
pulling them apart studying their
individual components reading out their
DNA but we don't actually understand how
all those components yet go back
together so one of the real reasons I'd
like to do this is to understand
learning by building and just as an
example of how bad we are in terms of
understanding natural biological systems
I'll show you this little movie that's a
research project it'll be published from
my lab these are a movie of bacteria
e.coli growing and dividing and all the
cells have been infected excuse me two
of the cells have been infected with a
virus and they'll turn green the two
infected cells and you'll see one of the
cells popped the virus is so tiny you
can't see it but you can see it destroys
the cell and the other cell just keeps
growing and dividing this is for a virus
that was first isolated from nature in
the 1950s its genome was read out 48,500
two base pairs in the 1980s so if you've
heard of the company 23andme for
studying human DNA you could have had a
company for this virus back in the
Reagan years we have no idea why one
cell will pop and the other cell will
continue to survive we have some stories
but no biophysical models so by learning
how to put these things back together by
taking the pieces as the biologists have
described them as these little entities
and trying to reassemble them we might
learn that our models of how these
things are actually parts though they're
not quite parts like we think
they are another reason I'm excited and
I'm arguing for getting better at
engineering biology developing tools
that support that and tools that support
humanity is to enable what I'll call
sustainable agility as well as artistry
and that might not be the right word I
might mean just simply beauty in terms
of sustainable agility folks might have
seen this before this is a comparison of
before and after corn or maize on the
left you see corn prior to domestication
and then on the right something that's
more familiar if you look at the foods
that we eat
we eat very few of the things that are
edible so far as plants are concerned
and so one thing I might hope for for
the future is agility with respect to
domesticating or whatever the equivalent
is different crops both as the
environment exists today and perhaps in
a changing environment toolkit so what
are some of the technologies that exist
today well to put this in context we've
lived in a world where for the last
human generation in the last 35 years
there's been since the invention of
recombinant DNA the birth of the modern
biotechnology industry companies like
Genentech here in the San Francisco area
and these are the tools if you will of
genetic engineering some of the most
basic tools for combatant DNA let's you
take two existing pieces of DNA and cut
and paste them making a new molecule
that might do something useful such as
produce insulin in bacteria so you get
that drug or reliably in service of
treating diabetes polymerase chain
reaction the second old tool lets you
take a single molecule of DNA and make
many many copies of it so it's more easy
to do stuff and then sequencing of DNA
lets you take a molecule and then read
it out getting access to the information
these are not the only tools that can
power the engineering of biology and
much of what I've used synthetic biology
to be about is the invention and
implementation of new tools so for
example construction of DNA rather than
manually manipulating DNA with enzymes
let me just have it constructed to order
biology's oftentimes there
complex maybe I can abstract it and
simplify it I'll give you examples of
four and five and then this turns out to
be a very radical idea maybe we could
standardize biology so that the
componentry can be reused more easily
here's some specific examples so DNA
construction it turns out that back in
1982 chemists working in Colorado more
or less perfected at the time a
chemistry called phosphoramidite
chemistry and what this means is you can
buy in jars chemicals today which are
derived from sugarcane and these
chemicals end up being the four bases of
DNA or phosphoramidites
in a form that can be readily assembled
so four of these bottles up at the top
here one would be a bottle of a T C and
G and so on and you hook these bottles
up to a machine into the machine comes
information from a computer a sequence
of DNA ta-a ta-a whatever you'd like to
build and that machine will stitch the
genetic material together from scratch
so if you've ever seen Star Trek where
they have the food replicating system
and you know I'd like a pumpkin spiced
mocha or latte or something and you can
compile that from the energy driver I
don't know exactly how it works
DNA synthesis is the equivalent
technology you take information in
material and you compile you take
information in the raw chemicals you
compile genetic material it's
practically speaking the coolest most
impressive / scary technology I've
encountered DNA is complicated so if we
were to do all our genetic engineering
at this level of resolution taa TAC TAC
TAC TAC IgG IgA it would become tedious
if not unreliable it would be a kin
perhaps the analogy is not perfect
perhaps like programming computer in
machine language at some point it might
be good to know how to do that but
oftentimes people would like to program
at a higher level and so some of these
ideas like abstraction of genetic
component tree involves the idea of
taking these different layers of
function the DNA layer and putting on
top of that a parts layer we could call
genetic objects that just do something
and you don't have to know all of the
sequence information and
we might be able to build still
higher-level functional objects like a
device that could receive or send
information or smell like bananas or
make a balloon and then maybe we could
have a system makes a drug swims around
finds a tumor and attacks it who knows
if we could pull this off what we'd end
up with is a future in which some people
could become expert systems engineers in
biology they could start to design and
build organisms and they wouldn't
actually need to know down at the bottom
that DNA was made up of four bases let
alone anything about phosphoramidite
chemistry they would compile down via
tools to the sequence level ship that
information over somebody would print
the DNA they get their DNA program back
they'd run it turns out we're working on
this there's a registry of standard
biological parts at this website today
you can get 3,500 biobrick DNA parts
they're freely available if you work at
a research university that's simply
because the legal system requires we
distribute these parts under what's
known as the research exemption this
collection of parts is growing
geometrically so two months ago it was
2,000 parts we just had students come in
with 1,500 more students do things like
this showing up in the lab dissatisfied
with the bouquet of e.coli how it smells
they decide to reprogram its stench if
the cell is growing smell like
wintergreen otherwise print banana smell
you could find a part that they made Jay
45 200 there's a DNA sequence when you
put that sequence of DNA into a bacteria
it smells like bananas
they were sufficient they accomplished
as teenagers first and second-year
undergraduates that they went live after
a couple months with a smell test demo
now along with this set of tools like
parts and standardization we're seeing
if I come back to the construction
business of DNA also a geometric
increase in the pace or capability of
DNA synthesis this is a paper published
within the last year where folks are
building from those raw chemicals from
scratch a piece of DNA almost 600
thousand base pairs long the length of a
small bacterial genome in fact the
biggest projects I've seen to date have
assembled pieces of DNA that are almost
10 million base pairs long almost the
size of the genome of baker's yeast
limits there's going to be some
interesting limits one to look ahead to
saw worthless talk from January probably
comes from energy Sol here is very
concerned about human civilization and
where we produce our energy and whether
or not we'll be able to transition to
something that's sustainable renewable
it turns out that biology has a thing on
our planet doesn't have access to that
much energy he estimates it might be
half a terawatt out of a civilization
our civilization that's running on
fifteen or eighteen terawatts maybe he's
wrong by a factor of ten and biology
really can get access to five terawatts
it's still not going to be an excess of
energy via biology so if you hear about
biofuels right now biofuels won't solve
our entire energy problem and because
there's a limitation there it's gonna
put tremendous pressure as I hope we
hear about on our land use and so on
security as I alluded to via the Ebola
sequence on the screen is a huge issue
and since the anthrax attacks in our
country back in 2001 we've spent over
sixty billion dollars in the name of
biosecurity this is largely resulted in
a reestablishment of classified
biosafety level four facilities BS BL
for facilities our facilities working on
most dangerous pathogens ironically the
FBI claimed to have traced the anthrax
attacks back to the very facilities
shown here and then we again come back
to the issues of communities and can our
generation going forward and beyond
bring together what might seem like
polar opposites on the left you see the
I gem community this is the genetic
engineering Olympic students doubling a
number practically every year on the
right people who are dissatisfied or
actively against the deployment of
genetic engineering I have some
proposals to consider and I'll quickly
show them here should teenagers practice
genetic engineering yes should military
force include biotech no well biohackers
be good or bad they'll be good if we
encourage them and celebrate them should
the parts be patented or shared they
should be free but maybe we have some
interesting terms and conditions to
discuss and so genetic engineers sign
their work yes
last slide I'm arguing for the
development of tools that make biology
easy to engineer in parallel I am
arguing that we also develop tools that
enable our humanity as we take
biotechnology forward thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]
outstanding errands everybody's Mike's
working hello that yep yep
great thank you very much true thank you
everyone for coming out on Monday
evenings really appreciate it and as
always it's great to hear a very
reflective technologist
may there be many more like you you
began your list of questions at the end
there and I'll start there by saying
should teenagers practice genetic
engineering yeah do you think they
should yeah who shouldn't shouldn't who
else
is was there a limit to who should use
these tools and what would that be I
think so long as somebody is disposed to
be constructive right and I might even
go further than that and say so long as
somebody is not disposed to be
destructive right that would be the
initial set right and then I'd open that
up for for wiser consideration but I
don't know that I would want to preclude
access to these technologies it seems my
gut tells me that many of the
technologies around biology have been
not officially locked up but hard to get
access to and I think it's ironic that
some of the difficulty in getting access
to the technology comes out of the
conversations of three decades ago where
issues of safety drove a very very
strong institutional oversight framework
to come into existence many of those
safety concerns were well-founded but as
a cost associated with that we now live
in a world where most people don't feel
comfortable talking about DNA or genetic
engineering most people presume that all
of the work is dangerous and you know
that's what we inherit if I look forward
you know there there are much more
serious dangers I get freaked out about
with respect to a future where a small
number of people have access to matter
compilers for genetic material imagine
if only one or two organizations in the
world have access to that technology
it's much more exciting for me to
imagine a world where anybody who might
usefully deploy biotechnology for a
local situation has
access to the tools has access to the
know-how and and can do it now that
might be a fantasy from any number of
perspectives but that's that's my
starting response and specifically then
you go and to say that you're concerned
if I get this right that the military
has access to this technology and what
would you do about that
matt meselson from Cambridge
Massachusetts a generation before was
part of a group who argued successfully
that the military the US government
should stand down its offensive
biological weapons program as I
understand it having inherited literally
not being alive at the time that that
that world and so the arguments is I
remember having learned them that they
made where geez we already have weapons
to we can't really control biological
weapons and three you know other people
could develop them and there's not
limited access to say nuclear material
with biology biology is everywhere so we
can't sort of lock up the raw materials
so they have no strategic value for us
and those those rational reasoned
arguments carried the day during the
Nixon administration I wonder to what
extent we're seeing today perhaps a
relaxing on some of those reasons maybe
we're getting better at controlling
biology and so we'd want to be vigilant
if you will to pay attention to the
debasement of any of those reasons but
another thing at least in the United
States has been a very very strong
immune response around biosecurity from
the anthrax attacks in the fall of a1 so
I'd like to just at least hold the line
around some of mesons arguments go back
and read Scientific American from from
that point in time you'll see hey we
should not have classified biosafety
level four facilities let's do this in
the open if we're gonna do anything so a
lot of the argumentation for for
developing for example the 1918 flu
virus was synthesized a few years ago
using synthetic biology there's a virus
that killed 50 million people in the
last century
yeah the argumentation was that it was
in order to defend against
and MX's flu that is still to come do
you accept that but that's non-military
or would you consider that military that
work was done at the CDC it was done in
public there was debate within the
research community as to whether or not
the sequence information for that 1918
flu should be made public not all the
researchers agreed it was made public it
was reviewed by the National Science
Advisory Board for biosecurity before it
was published and the scientific
community rallied behind that the
arguments basically being made or of the
form no disease had been has been cured
in secret and we have to we have to keep
this stuff in the open others
notable around this part of the world
bill joy and ray kurtzweil had a nice
editorial in the New York Times saying
this is the most irresponsible thing
they'd encountered I think the
scientific community would point to the
subsequent work and say it was good to
have that information out there we've
understood a little bit more about the
evolution of the flu and it's not
something that should be done without
concern for safety issues but it was the
right thing to do so you talked about
agility you talked about understanding
nature I mean another reason that you
appear to be invoked with synthetic
biology is that you're actually a
founder and on the board of a commercial
company using synthetic biology what's
the role of Commerce in understanding
nature and building ideology that's a
great question I was attracted to being
involved with a company because one of
the core technologies in synthetic
biology DNA synthesis has little or no
public support and so if you wanted to
get better at that technology when the
commercial sector the investment sources
came up and said we're willing to help
with this now that was an eye-opener for
me I've seen the strengths and
weaknesses of what you can do in a
commercial sector it's surprising to me
that there is not public recognition of
the importance of DNA synthesis
technology and how the public probably
wants to consider having an active voice
in seeing this technology developed so
has a say in how its deployed and I was
I was really taken by one of your last
slides well II want later on when you
were talking about agility and creating
agility what you showed was teosinte the
original in ancestor four maze and then
he shows the maze plant well there's a
plant that was developed through open
source means sure without genetic
engineering and so that seems to be an
argument for agility without biotech
FISMA
well I'd argue that maze is a
biotechnology
it's a bio technology developed by
particular methods over a particular
period of time by agility I mean to the
extent that it's possible and I'm
perfectly happy to recognize what's
research and what's ready to be
commercialized to the extent that it's
possible if we needed to do that faster
not waiting for many many many
generations I'd like to have that
capability and you know you're very
closely identified with open source
biotechnology trying to to make sure
that this moves ahead it's shared but
there have been people on this stage I
think who are pushing for patents in
this area how do you defend against that
how do you defend against patents I'd
rather avoid that question and and and
ask answer a related question just to be
honest which is how do you develop an
open technology platform and you develop
an open technology platform so far as I
can figure by doing two things one you
build a community and two you protect
against encumbrance of reuse and
combination meaning when you take any
two things and give them away somebody
else could take those two things put
them together and say oh this is mine so
how do you do those two things and in
biotechnology patents are the dominant
form of protecting against encumbrance
of reuse in combination we can't afford
it with another fifteen hundred parts
coming into the collection that's thirty
million dollars in patent fees and if
you were to give me thirty million bucks
I'd go make more parts and
practically then what that means is we
have to build a community that grows
faster and can out-innovate trolls who
will inevitably come around the
periphery there's some other things we
can do we could talk about that in more
detail so so I'm not for or against
patents but I think you know patents per
se have a cost associated with them they
have a time constant associated with
them they have a lag and that makes them
exclusive and so I think a lot of the
innovation and pacing of innovation in
biotech and and and the good that can
come from it would be better realized by
having complementary frameworks that
might operate on shorter time scales or
have lower transaction costs so if
happens have a cost but they also have a
very clear opportunity which is why
people take them out a number of the
parts in the bio bricks are actually
patented so do you not see a situation
where this is just going to get
subverted most pieces of DNA on the
planet have not been patented the uses
of fragments of DNA there are a great
number of patents in the United States
and in Japan and fewer elsewhere so with
respect to the BioBricks collection our
challenge right now is to take something
which is openly distributed within a
research community so researchers at
universities can use stuff you know
under what's called the research
exemption how do we make that accessible
to people within the commercial space or
outside the research community so we're
doing okay now but we need to basically
extend our community and figure out how
to do that so we're working on an
agreement with lawyers and hope to have
that ready for public comment but it is
a tricky problem for us time up ahead so
you know what I heard very clearly you
said that a number of times was you're
interested in making biology easier to
engineer and it sounds like you don't
really want to put any limits on that
and who uses it
who can engineer you want that to be a
generally available platform and you
want to supplement that with tools that
would allow humanity to behave more
wisely or something like that tools for
Humanity I think is
put it and your reasons for this is that
by rebuilding nature from this from this
fundamental place that you want to
understand how nature works better it's
a building by understanding and then you
had an argument around what you called
agility that having more technological
tools in our toolbox means that we can
deal with some of the great pressures
that are coming down the pike whether
that's climate change or hunger in the
case of food and then you know you
talked about some of the limits that you
do see in this field or some of the
challenges and those challenges included
you know that we have limits on energy
use that mean that this probably isn't
the appropriate way to go about
answering energy concerns with biofuels
and that you were concerned certainly
about the military use of this
technology and you had other questions
about should teenagers use this and you
thought they should and and you had some
concerns about the intellectual property
framework and you feel it should be as
free and open as possible it's that kind
of everything we leave out that's
ninety-three percent correct that's
terrific
actually I would not like to enable
people who actively seek to cause harm
with the psychology so whether it's a
nation call it the military of the
nation whether it's an organization or
an individual criminal yeah not a hacker
but a criminal I guess I would emphasize
just complimenting what you said that
it's very hard to look ahead on some of
this technology given the geometric
increase and some of the capabilities so
sequencing and synthesis both but
synthesis in particular as a technology
is getting better year after year after
year much like computers are if you're
familiar with Moore's law and so little
bits of uncertainty projecting along
those Exponential's lead to interesting
futures
but I think no matter what things are
likely to happen pretty quickly yeah so
maybe just to complement what you said
add that to the speed yeah great thank
you yeah you're on great thank you
Thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
so em thank you drew and to Stuart them
along now my colleague Pat Mooney who's
after much longer now than I have
reckons that it takes roughly a human
generation to understand the impacts of
our technology and I think he's probably
being a bit short on that I think it's
something more like a human lifetime so
I'm not really expecting we're going to
get a very clear reading on synthetic
biology tonight or anytime soon but I am
gonna argue that that lag between
deploying our technologies and
understanding our technologies is a good
reason why we should be supplementing
the art of the long view with that
policy of the long path by which I mean
the deliberate careful path of
precaution and I note that I've been
billed as a historian tonight and that's
a big shoes to fill and especially as I
bumped off most my history degree doing
direct action but I'm gonna try and not
disappoint and to bring at least a few
lessons from history particularly
lessons from the closest parallel that I
can find which is the synthetic chemical
industry and apart from the name and the
fact that DNA synthesis is a chemistry
technique and what these two two fields
share is they're both about building
synthesizing nature from standard
molecular parts and indeed the early
chemists believed that they could
understand nature better by building it
just as drew does but I think the
parallel that we're looking at right now
with synthetic biology as the mid 19th
century when the synthetic chemists
began to commercialize their field I
just want to quickly show you how
parallel those two moments are so if you
go out to 1856 this was the time when a
teenager in East London called William
Henry Perkin who was supposed to be
synthesizing a anti-malarial drug
quitting ended up synthesizing a
synthetic dye moving and realizing this
was a red hot commercial prospect he
commercialized it and a bunch of French
and German and Swiss entrepreneurs the
sort of mid 19th century equivalents of
craig Venter or Vinod Khosla copied his
his business model and they they also
started producing synthetic dyes and on
the back of this synthetic dye industry
the modern chemical industry was born
where he's it for 150 years
and just across the bay Jay Keasling is
also trying to synthesize an
anti-malarial compound this time
artemisinin using biology and he finds
out that he can synthesize gasoline he
sets up a biofuels business and people
like Vinod Khosla and craig Venter copy
their idea and before you know it you
have a booming synthetic life industry
and what's interesting is that this new
synthetic life industry is following
some of the same questions that the
synthetic chemists faced a hundred and
fifty years ago so here's drew dealing
with questions about monopolies and I
hope you don't mind but I think they're
very 19th century view of monopolies
that you have in the middle of the 19th
century you had a booming open source
movement and they roll back with the
patent movement the patent laws that
really allowed the industry to take off
within a very short time however that
itself had been rolled back in the mid
1970s a bunch of German companies
lobbied for a strong patent law they
used that to build a very strong
monopoly which by 1925 was a G Farben
our fourth largest monopoly in the world
and since that time the chemical
industry has been a highly concentrated
and highly powerful industry right
through to now and if you look at BASF
which is one of those original companies
it's now the largest chemical company
it's also got a one and a half billion
dollar agreement with Monsanto on GMO
season it's positioned itself at the
head of the pack on nanotechnology so we
moved in that case from monopoly to
oligopoly and I think we're gonna see
this exactly this with synthetic biology
that well there's an attempt to build a
commons we're already seeing patents
being placed being written by people
like craig Venter and DuPont which are
being set to crowd out the commons and
establish a monopoly position there is
going to be a microbe soft of synthetic
biology and I salute the attempts to
kick against that but I think history is
on the side of craig Venter on this one
and drew is concerned about
militarization and rightly so there you
go back to the history of synthetic
chemistry back in the 1850s you have
people like Lionel Playfair a British
chemist saying that you could use
chemistry in the Crimean War for for for
chemical
weapons and this this caused a real stir
we had at least two treaties trying to
ban chemical weapons but by the time the
first world war came around both the
Allies and the Germans were releasing
synthetic chlorine into the wind to try
and gas their opponents two decades
later IG Farben BASF again was was
supplying zyklon-b into the gas chambers
at Auschwitz
now if he'd said to the founders of BASF
in the 1860s that their facilities would
be used to carry out mass murder by
their own government they would have
said that was an extreme and improbable
thing but the balance of probability
changed very quickly across one human
lifetime and I really do think that it's
a it's a mistake to think that with
synthetic biology where we already have
had agents built that can kill 50
million people as it did last last
century in the case of 1918 flu virus
that you can on the one hand restrain
the hostile uses of this technology and
on the other hand have a booming
industry that really is a fairy tale
that high-tech companies and high-tech
industries tell their population to try
and make them sleep better at night
I think if drew is serious about disarm
in the future you have to realize that
the existence of an industry and a
capacitor dust really pasady means that
they will be commandeered in wartime by
states even states that you think he
trusts and the way to disarm the future
is to disarm the large-scale commercial
production of anything using synthetic
biology and I think thirdly looking back
to the chemical industry there's a clear
lesson on economic disruption you didn't
have to wait for soldiers to be killed
on the battlefield before they were
already economic deaths on the
agricultural fields of turkey of Mexico
and of India that in fact those who grew
the natural dyes further the dyestuffs
industry saw the emergence of a
synthetic dye stuffs industry back in
the 1860s as a attack on first their
livelihoods in later their lives so in
1897 BASF and Baier had a synthetic
indigo dye blue which led to the
collapse of indigo growing in in Bengal
75%
that area planted to indigo collapsed
within a decade and then when famine
came along I was unemployed millions of
unemployed growers ended up dead
and those are just the sort of first
Canaries in the coal mine we've first
seemed wave after wave of synthetic
products made by chemistry putting out
of work rubber tappers and cotton
producers and so forth but I think
synthetic biology is probably gonna
outdo all of that I mentioned already
Jay Keasling which is one of Jews
colleagues and he has a project to
working with sanofi-aventis to replace
Artemisia which is usually grown by
thousands of small farmers in East
Africa and Southeast Asia and basically
to undercut them and put them out of
business um but it goes further when I
spoke with Jay Keasling recently he told
me that as far as he was concerned
synthetic biology meant that anything
that can be made from a plant can now be
made by a microbe in a vat think about
that anything that can be made from a
plant can now be made by a microbe in a
vat a statement like that if it's true
is the death knell for economies that
depend on plant derived commodities
whether that's tropical oils or fibers
or rubber or plant extracts for
pharmaceuticals and flavorings and so
forth what Jay Keasling statement means
is that for the customers of those
commodity dependent countries which are
usually the poorest countries in the
world they can now dangle the carrots or
the concern of synthetic biology and
then renegotiate costs they can
renegotiate trade deals they can switch
to microbial synthesis and leave whole
nations up in the air potentially it's a
spiral into hunger violence and unrest
so monopoly militarization massive
economic destruction three things that
we can already see from the beginning of
this and the last synthetic industry but
the real doozie was synthetic chemistry
came a full century later and that's in
1962 and Rachel Carson published Silent
Spring and drew back the curtain on a
host of unexpected toxicities of what
was thought to be the good side
synthetic chemistry the pesticides that
paints their fertilizers the
refrigerants and so forth the whole
better living through chemistry package
and for showing that tremendous cost
that those benefits were paid for by she
was called emotional unscientific she
was called a fear monger all these sort
of labels that today get put on people
who are critical of biotechnology and
but she really didn't even have a part
of it
some years after Rachel Carson's death
Joe and I are now part of a generation
with the lowest sperm count in history
under a depleted ozone layer and every
night my wife feeds my child
breast milk with persistent organic
pollutants in and we're the privileged
ones for communities of color and poor
communities in the shadow of chemical
facilities the attack of the synthetic
chemical industry on their lives and
their health is something more like a
slow genocide which is not to say
synthetic biology is going to be toxic
but it is to say we need to properly way
that which we do not know and we need to
take it extremely serious and that's
being discussed on this stage before
it's the Black Swan that Nassim Taleb
talks about or Paul Sappho's cone of
uncertainty in the case of synthetic
biology we already have significant
questions over some of the assumptions
underlying the notion that DNA is a code
that can be programmed and is heritable
and so forth but if you have those
questions we shouldn't be moving into
commercial use and that's why civil
society generally calls for a very
strong use of the precautionary
principle in this case maybe we can
discuss that more I want to end with
three mistakes that I see looming in the
longer-term for synthetic biology to
open up our questions
first the discussion so far is just
about microbes and we're soon going to
see synthesis of plants of animals and
certainly of human beings and we should
think what that means
secondly we absolutely mustn't try and
treat synthetic biology with the same
set of regulatory and governance tools
that we use for genetically modified
organisms they are different quantitive
ly and qualitatively
qualitatively you're not talking about a
small piece of DNA taken from somewhere
in nature and then put into a genome
that you mostly already have existing in
nature to try and understand the
biosafety of that countries use
something called substantial equivalence
the kind of pseudo-scientific biosafety
tool doesn't work well with GMOs
absolutely won't work with synthetic
biology where you're going to be
designing entirely novel sequences of
DNA and increasingly putting it into an
entirely novel genome so we don't yet
have any models predictive models for
working out the biosafety of these
synthetic organisms and I think that's
going to be a black hole in switch this
whole field is going to get sucked
quantitive Lee it's different to if drew
successful at making biology easier to
engineer such that anybody teenagers or
whatever can can do this we're going to
see a massive increase in the number of
engineered organisms entering the
biosphere I discovered there's an
amazing job that somebody has here in
the Bay Area which is from NASA and
there's the planetary protection officer
it's got to be the coolest job there is
an apparently her job is to make sure
that no alien life-forms
get into the biosphere I think she's
looking at the wrong place I think she
should be checking out the synthetic
biology labs and particularly the
synthetic biology labs of J craig Venter
who claims in his patents and in his
public pronouncements that he has a
method of making millions of new species
every day think about that millions of
new species every day I mean what does
that mean it means probably that Kevin
Kelly's all species directory is going
to have to go find a whole lot more
storage and it means that the taxonomy
so not going to sleep for the next
hundred years but what does that mean
for the biosphere which is already under
stress from climate change and chemicals
and so forth
we know that alien species introduced
into the biosphere or into into
different parts of the biosphere the
second worst cause of species extinction
which finally brings me to third and I
think the biggest mistake that this
field is is committing and that's that
it's adopting an extremely destructive
business plan actually drew who's
touched on this
so far as far as I can see the synthetic
biology business plan is make a microbe
that turns sugar into something usually
biofuels maybe chemicals and this is
often expressed as the so called bio
economy which is going to replace
petroleum with sugar and whether its
food sugars such as corn or cane but we
know that's a bad idea from from ethanol
that if you use food sugars you're going
to be displacing food and that pushes up
prices and pushes people into hunger or
more usually the suggestion is long term
it's going to be cellulose that's to say
the woody part of our plants and I think
accessing that woody part of our plants
is is a very dangerous move we're going
to see a massive corporate grab on plant
biomass in the coming years facilitates
facilitated by synthetic biology and and
I'd really like to talk more about how
significant that is so here's the
difference between Jareau and I we
actually share a lot of values and we do
talk from time to time but drew
basically advocates for the fastest
possible diffusion of these synthetic
biology tools and I basically am in
favor of a deliberate containment policy
to offer a basket of mixed metaphors I
think we should be slamming on the
brakes
certainly on commercialization that we
should be locking this up in the lab
until we really understand it that we
should be divorcing the science from the
commercial world that's a disaster and
that we should be very carefully looking
before we leap and we need to be doing
all of these things right now because a
very powerful commercial synthetic life
industry is coming into being right now
and that window for polite debates like
this is rapidly closing thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
well that's terrific many questions to
start I had not sure this is the right
question so that's as a preface the
first one is there some way you think
practically to protect nature so you
talked about the use of these tools by
commercial agents to get access to the
remaining three-quarters of the biomass
that's not now a commodity if you will
is is there some practical way from your
perspective to protect what's still not
a commodity and is it only linked to
decoupling the technology development
from industry and commercialization well
that's part of it I mean I think yes so
as you say 24% plant biomass is
currently used by a civilization that
leaves about was that 76% or so ready to
be commercialized once we have a way of
commercializing and commodifying it and
so I you know very straightforward way
is just not to develop those tools not
to develop the tools that turn cellulose
into a usable sugar to make plastics and
biofuels that's that that lands that
stays with the technologists for the
world's governments to enact very strong
treaties we have the Convention on
Biological Diversity which is exists for
the sustainable use and conservation of
biodiversity that's a place that should
be making a very clear statement that
that those I think the key point here is
that they're those synthetic biologists
and others who say that you know we have
this available cellulose whether it's
leftover corn stalks or it's wooden
forests make the cent give the cents and
it's a lie this is somehow available and
the corn stalks that are left behind on
the field are exactly what you need to
build the soil so you can grow the food
the next generation that's not available
at all it's not available and it
shouldn't be made available and to steal
that is to destroy the soil if we
destroy the soil as Franklin Roosevelt
the nation said the nation that destroys
the soil destroys itself
absolutely right in the forests the idea
is the forest to somehow store houses of
carbon and sugar that we can just access
when we want it's not true
they're vast vast ecosystems that clean
our water and clean our air and we need
to absolutely protect and defend those
and the means for doing that are at the
level of the tools development and their
commercialization part I think that I
see you know if you want to create
social change there's there's two things
one is that you have to have social
organizing and that's that's legal and
political organizing and social
organizing the other is you need to
prevent encroaching threats and what I
see is was developing in synthetic
biology our encroaching threats threats
to to this the cellulose locked up in
all those forests and I want to disable
those threats you mentioned that Jay
Keasling x' project on the East Bay
involved taking a microbe in a vat and
making artemisinin for treating malaria
is it ever okay to make something in a
vat filled with microbes and how would
you decide if it's okay yeah and yeah
yeah beer is a great thing to make an
event and in fact I believe amarus
started by making beer and I think we
should just stopped at that point and
with their recent the recent plant over
Emeryville I think the question here is
and it's the general question for
technology if you if you're going to
develop for technology that impacts
people on the other side of the world
they have to have a say in the
development of that technology what this
means is we need to have much more
reflective and participative methods of
assessing our technology is very very
early on so we can identify who's going
to be impacted and we can bring them
into the discussion the problem here is
a justice problem that amarus bio
technologies and and whoever's invested
in them is about to make a killing maybe
literally off of something that's going
to undercut the livelihoods of thousands
of people in East Africa and we need a
process and this is a bigger technology
question we need a process by which that
can be flagged up and and there can be
some sort of intervention
given that that work was sponsored by
the Gates Foundation do you find that
surprising or ironic it's not entirely
surprising but a large monopoly that
tries to move into the area of
development also ends up replicating its
problems in the area of development but
I think it's definitely worrying and my
understanding from talking with with Jay
was that they were actually told that
that they should they should move on to
make another business and so that's what
made them move into biofuels which is
the second problem and we have a lack of
governance over large powerful and
foundations as well and we need to
control that when computers some of the
modern computers were first built phone
by von neumann and his team in the 1950s
those were commissioned to design
hydrogen bombs and so on and today we
live in a world where going through a
transition about a generation ago people
got basically fed up with limited access
to computers and started making their
own do you see any possible paths around
a biotechnology that might not be into
militarization even if nation-states go
bad or rogue or what-have-you yeah or is
that is that really inevitable I you
know I think I think if there's a
technology which a state can use for its
own interests or a powerful entity
whether it's a corporation or whatever
can use there's a pretty good chance
it's going to get used so I'm reasonably
pessimistic I think I if this technology
is going to be developed in a way that's
very deliberate then that deliberateness
has to try and reduce the ability for it
to get into the hands of overly powerful
players we live in an unjust world and
if we're introducing a powerful
technology into an unjust world we're
going to probably exacerbate that
injustice unless we're very very
deliberate and trying to to attack that
injustice I don't see that happening now
I didn't see that happening and I am not
quite sure how it would happen if you
could draft part of the biobrick public
license is there a term or a clause or a
condition beyond just you're free to use
it that you'd like to see hard-coded in
there yeah plenty what would be a
cluster your top three it's my eye I
would I would put two lines that
shouldn't be crossed so and if they are
crossed that I was further one the first
line is that there should be no release
into the biosphere of anything produced
using these parts and that would keep it
locked up in the lab and if it ends up
released into the biosphere and we need
to be they needs to be a legal mechanism
to to come back on that there needs to
be a crime civil law may be you know
ability to try and get some sort of
liability the second would be that these
these parts shouldn't be commercialized
and that this is safe is this truly for
understanding how nature works which i
think is a genuinely good reason to do
synthetic biology there's no need to
release them into the biosphere as a
sort of uncontrolled experiment so that
would be a second one and and I think
there's you know a question of okay if
there's an overwhelming need maybe this
is comes to your question earlier
there's an overwhelming need to cross
one of those lines to release into the
environment or to to commercialize this
technology then there needs to be a very
transparent and participative process
for assessing the technology where
communities beyond the synthetic
biologists particularly marginalized
communities will be affected gets how to
say over whether this moves ahead I'm
not ruling out there might be some use
somewhere in the future which which
everybody agrees to but I think that has
to be done deliberately and with
vigilance do you think there's any role
for civil society organizations to play
in the development of the technology so
that they can better constrain or guide
their deployment or lack thereof
yeah and civil society organizations
tend to
you know it's a way basket of groups but
they network across many different
communities and can bring different
types of knowledge to assessing
technologies and so I think there's a
very powerful role for not just civil
society communities and social movements
but also indigenous peoples communities
and other groups to to bring
perspectives and knowledge on which
technologies we feel more comfortable
with them and to have some kind of
participative assessments and so in the
role of assessment certainly one last
question a lot of times as technologies
have been developed and it becomes
easier to make stuff you can see an
increase in diversity could you foresee
a future where humans by their ability
to make or change living organisms
contribute to biological diversity in a
way that's constructive or could be
celebrated so you know we know this we
brought drew to the Convention on
Biological Diversity and I think you
know part of your argument there was you
know we'll make biological diversity
it's not a great idea I think I find
that unlikely though the experiences I
think I mentioned of introducing new
species into into an environment is
usually that they reduce biological
diversity and my worry is that's what's
going to happen I think you know I'm not
the only person to say this Freeman
Dyson has written a really interesting
essay in which you suggest that you know
if we start producing large quantities
of new engineered organisms by amateurs
we're probably going to lose a lot of
the species that we already have he
seems fine with that I'm pretty
uncomfortable with it okay thank you
very much
to summarize Jim
notes that there is a lag to the
understanding that humans have sort of
consequences of developing new
technologies and you mentioned that Pat
Mooney said it might be a human
generation 30 years or so but you
actually thought it was longer 70 years
or a hundred years and so from that
opening you submitted for our
consideration argued that the policy of
the long path leading to a precaution in
considering and bringing forward new
technologies is paramount
he used synthetic chemistry as a
parallel and and highlighted many
different aspects that that seem to be
parallel perhaps with synthetic biology
noting for example the work of Perkin in
1856 developing a dye in England and
then seeing that readily and rapidly
commercialized by the French and others
and this rapid industrialization
perhaps at the time was if I understood
correctly coupled to open patent
frameworks but then that was sort of
subject to the tides of the time or the
decades and rolled back at various
points leading eventually but also
somewhat quickly to what you'd call a
concentration of power this
concentration of power then leads to
misapplication many horrible things that
were aware of with chemicals being
misapplied back in World War one in
World War Two and even more recently the
economic impact of the development of
chemicals also synthetic biology and
chemicals produced via biology
oftentimes contributes to
disenfranchisement impoverishment of
people who are not represented in the
process of the development or the
deployment commercialization of the
technology further along in the
development of synthetic chemistry you
noted Rachel Carlson's experience and
the generations leading up to that and
what we inherit around the impact of
synthetic chemicals on the environment
on humans drawling back the curtain on
basically uncontrolled experiments
I think you might have noted that
biology is at least as serious as
chemistry might have been if for no
other reason that the things that we're
constructing can reproduce themselves
whereas oftentimes chemicals to get made
once and they go hopefully they get
diluted or destroyed
so in summary around this part of your
remarks you you came back to again the
idea of precaution as a principle and
the development of this new technology
you noted that the conversation seems
quite likely to move beyond microbes
quickly so if it's microbes today it's
plants tomorrow and technically I would
agree with that you thought that this
was not like genetic engineering it
might be an outgrowth of genetic
engineering from the tools perspective
but in terms of the regulatory framework
it's a whole different beast and that
new approaches are needed if for example
you're compiling an entire organism from
scratch and there's nothing to compare
it to then what do we compare it to how
do we know if it's safe does that
challenge our biosafety framework in
some way you noted that there might
likely be a massive increase of
organisms released into the biosphere
and if most new things coming into the
biosphere if anything successful and
takes over it's likely to have a
traumatic effect on the rest of things
and lead to a loss of diversity in
particular you noted a problem mistake
of vulnerability associated with the
further commodification of sugar sugar
plus cellulose and how this provides
access to all of the the the natural
living world in a way that just simply
hasn't been true before that this could
lead to further concentrations of power
you know drawing on some remarks I
remember from hongkong increases in
landless peasants in Brazil for example
and so forth so to summarize you
concluded by arguing for slamming on the
brakes that we lock the technology of
synthetic biology into the laboratories
we decouple the industrialization the
commercial
of the technology from the laboratory
work and that we go forward with care
great care one more thing I did note
that the notion that you could you could
develop a viable commercial industry and
not expected to be militarized as a
fairy tale and I think that's important
the states will will press a commercial
industry into wartime use and I think
motion that should be in mind otherwise
yeah you got it thank you thank you guys
the cover the question I have drew and
you can look over his shoulder Jim
you've seen a number of things come into
the iGEM jamberries Kids on the loose
insanely creative grabbing your
BioBricks and running off in weird
directions with them and as you see
these things coming in have any of them
entered a category that makes you
nervous and it's so fly and you've
probably know some things that are in a
category that would make Jim nervous and
why do they not make you nervous so some
cases from my jam I think is what I'm
looking for here
I'll start at the Jamboree so Stewart
noted in his opening remarks that when
he was at Stanford there was not a
department of bioengineering and when I
moved to MIT back in January 2002 there
was not a department of biological
engineering and one of the things I was
involved with with good colleagues there
was to get that started and we graduated
our first class of students last June
the students desires coming in to
research University and seeing biology
not as a science only but as a
technology include learning how to
design and build living organisms right
DNA programs that work and so on we
don't know really how to teach them how
to do that and what I showed today in
terms of technical substance is really
state of the art sometimes controversial
as far as technology itself is concerned
meaning is this really going to work or
not the students are helping us figure
out how to take this forward and so high
gem the International genetically
engineered machines competition you can
think of it as a genetic engineering
Olympics for undergraduates this started
as a class of 16 students at MIT back in
2003 it's grown by a factor of about two
every year so we just had an end of
competition Jamboree a weekend or two
weekends ago at MIT with about 850
students from all over the world
I've not been concerned via an IgM
project we ask our students and I gem to
by themselves assess the safety issues
associated with their project and so if
I were to start with safety that one is
creatively addressed the students also
have to note if there's anybody local
who is concerned with issues of safety
officially at their institutions and so
hi gem itself exists within a very
strong institutional oversight framework
derived from the experiences with
recombinant DNA it's not been perfect
but it's worked okay I have had one
example of a project which did concern
me it was a sophomore not part of AI gem
but in a laboratory course and she
decided that it was a shame if you will
if not worse that people who had
wrinkles had to go for repeated
injections at the plastic surgeon's
office of a bacterial toxin Botox and
wouldn't it be better if you could have
a skin cream that was a living skin
cream that would make small amounts of
this toxin on your face and so she set
off to design that and we thought that
was a bad idea and had a conversation
and it points to you know that this is
gonna move into human enhancement and
that's going to be a discussion but I
would actually go back to something that
you just said which is when Jo and I
first met or would even meet actually it
was because the the synthetic biology
community had decided they were going to
pass resolution at synthetic biology 2.0
their large conference here in the Bay
Area and that they wanted
self-regulation voluntary oversight and
self-regulation of their own field and
that worried many of us and civil
society very strongly because you know
I'd say the inventor of an to quote
Plato the inventor of an art is not the
best one to consider the risks and
benefits that might accrue from it
they're a little bit biased and and it's
lightly worries me that the safety
framework and assessment framework for
IEM is the students themselves determine
if there's any safety issues that
shouldn't be the way the field go
had been needs to be an external way of
doing it's combined with community
oversight many of the community
oversight boards include not just
researchers but members of the public it
isn't perfect and it's different all
over the world and so I gem provides a
way of promulgating a framework much
faster than a government might but
otherwise you know very much in
agreement I've got a question for you
Jim from Thurston where's Thursday would
the first vat of beer have passed the
precautionary principle yes and actually
ever that's the first bat of human
insulin that was created by genetically
engineered bacteria yes so one of it one
of the issues that to directly answer
your question I don't know with the case
of beer I think if somebody had consumed
that beer they probably would have
decided it wasn't a very cautionary
thing to move ahead with the that one of
the things I think that worries me about
the development of synthetic biology and
many of our technology at the moment is
the speed which is what drew pointed to
where we're developing at a speed where
there isn't any reflection there isn't a
space for reflection because it they
could then through commercialization
also get deployed at a scale where we
can't draw back now in the case of fire
which isn't you know kind of already
existed and you could observe it in the
natural world I guess nonetheless you
know if you're developing it over a long
period of time many of our early
technologies would have been developed
over thousands of years and at a scale
where we can pull back that's a kind of
precautionary framework of its own as
for insulin and yeah that's I think
there's still that's an interesting
debate and and you know I wonder if some
folks would consider that to be
sort of necessary react reaction to diet
if you will in part that's not
completely fair but I just to support
Jim a little bit you know there are
things that are impressive about
biology's of technology you have
reproducing machines really and we
depend on biology utterly which
everybody is well aware and so it's not
like you could reformat the hard drive
our knowledge base is nowhere near being
able to do that so the consequences of
screwing something up seem much more
serious than we might be familiar with
regarding beer or fire even Saul
Griffiths is here so this I think
question is mainly for you drew what is
the best testing methodology for sin by
Allah but best being safest and the ads
can abstraction really exist without
perfect compilers and therefore are
imperfect compilers which we have risk
and he asks a question I don't
understand what you might how about the
component combine it Tarek's being
considered obvious and IP and answer
would help elsewhere I saw where so ok
well perfect compilers in terms of being
able to build DNA maybe we can get
better at that and if not perfect pretty
good good enough combinatoric s-- being
obvious I think what Saul's referring to
there is the idea if you've put two
things together in combination and get
some useful invention therefrom it's
obvious right and if it's obvious and it
can't be patented would that the Patent
Office followed that prescription which
we simply don't see in practice and
biotechnology what's the first part of
Saul's question I got so distracted
oh the best methodology of testing
methodology where best equals safest
that's your work sores holy moley well
you know we don't we don't have a
physics model for a cell is the way to
think about it you know we we have a
decent physics model for planes and so
you can simulate wings and whatnot and
do pretty good on a computer and then
have a chance of flying the plane when
you take it out on the runway for the
first time and because we don't have a
physics model for life either inside a
cell or let alone the ecosystem you
don't see people forecasting evolution
yet it's a real tricky question to
answer and the only way I know to test a
biological system forget about safety
but but just test it at all is to build
it is to compile it to a physical object
and see what it does and so what that
means practically is we need a very
strong containment framework that
addresses issues of safety which is what
we have to a degree in is the biosafety
framework based on containment has four
levels one two three four yeah so
biosafety level one would be something
like the Jota cold project where folks
are cutting and pasting DNA to reprogram
the bouquet of a bacteria this work when
it's done for the first time should be
done in a closed laboratory with
individuals who have been through a
biosafety process the output of their
research whether it's dirty plates or
flasks containing old bacteria should be
autoclaved or boiled or cooked so
they're destroyed or bleached so that
things are not wantin ly leaving the
laboratory environment so that would be
biosafety level one it's meant to
provide a minimal containment around
some of the lowest risk if you will
genetic engineering work biosafety level
four as the subject of thrillers right
so the hot zone or what have you
pathogens for which there's no treatment
or cure Ebola other hemorrhagic fevers
and so on these are secured facilities
under negative pressure so that the air
if there's a leak should flow in and so
on tremendous controversy around these
facilities both their development
staffing siting I think so
he noted at a civil society teachin last
Thursday that one of the biosafety level
4 facilities was recently put on a
barrier island on the Gulf of Mexico so
you can debate whether or not that's
wise so that's the biosafety framework
and and if you go online you can get a
lot of information about it
what should amateurs do about biosafety
I think I think we I think we have to
create something new in our society that
might be akin to what you've seen with
amateur radio combined with the homebrew
Computer Club combined with something
else I'm not quite sure what that is but
folks are basically gonna have to if
they want to participate in this
research in their garage if they wanted
to garage biotech they have two options
one option is to do a lot of work on
their laptop right to do the design work
at the DNA level has information and
ship that information over the internet
to laboratories which are already safely
established to compile and test so that
would be one option another option would
be to provide a minimal assessed
approved bl1 facility in your garage
which would be possible to do it's done
basically whoo it didn't things like
that or what you'd have to limit access
to the facility you have to demonstrate
that you were practicing good microbial
safety so you weren't releasing things
into the trash you'd have to destroy all
of the organisms before you disposed of
them and so on and by organisms of
talking about bacteria or yeast or so on
so this is part of how you report to the
homebrew computer the homebrew biotech
club that you're part of that you're
doing all these things and one would
wonder whether it needed stronger
oversight right so if you have if you're
an amateur radio operator you actually
have to have to get a license right
maybe you want something akin to that
Jim what do you think well well I mean
first are these on computers or radio
they're talking about living things and
then we know that living things escape
from labs all the time and so I so what
do you mean by that well there's a very
you know there are regular incidences
genetically modified organisms escaping
from university labs that happens all
the time but what worries me actually is
the area I'm more worried about a
commercial facility so you know Honduras
biotech has just set up a biorefinery in
Emeryville they're also setting one up
in the Brazilian countryside this is
roughly speaking a brewery and I don't
even ask biosafety level 1 2 3 or 0.5
yeah where are the where are the
controls on commercialization and what
are the things we're probably gonna miss
in that process so we could talk about
that right I guess we'd have to also
bring into it the hope in fermenters in
in Europe around you know brewing beer I
have to assume and would like to go ask
the people at amorous what sort of by a
safety review Henryville ask them to do
right is there a risk associated with
yeast that produced diesel fuel and if
so what is it and does it somehow
persists if you know it definitely
doesn't persist into the fuel I mean
those kind of questions
buy persist you mean the organism yeah
yeah um later to this question it from
Kevin Hart or blur is it even possible
to regulate synthetic biology isn't
Pandora's box already open and if so it
isn't open source the best defense you
said the window is closing fast
this question it says maybe the window
is closed and I hope that the window is
closing and you can pretty much count on
all my fingers and maybe Drew's the
companies that call themselves synthetic
biology companies you can probably if
you had a you worked very hard at it
kind of identify all the people who use
synthetic biology techniques you
probably know a large number of them
it's still something that could still be
contained as a as a as an enterprise and
so if we wanted to contain this in a
laboratory and prevent commercialization
Society could choose to do this
I agree that with the price of DNA
synthesis going down and the ease with
which you can buy a DNA synthesizer on
eBay that's rapidly diminishing the last
time I knew everybody in the synthetic
biology community was in 2005 or 2006
with 850 students showing up at the IEM
Jamboree this year it was all I could do
to coordinate the judging of that event
I don't know everybody individually and
so that's uh that's just the state of
affairs it is a distributed technology
it is relatively cheap and you know I
wonder back to something you said around
concentration of power and large
commercial actors my sense is you know
if we keep coming back to amorous that's
actually a small company that's 200
people you could do a lot with a team of
12 people in this space and so whether
it's out of the box or in the box I'm
not even sure there's a box left would
be one way to think about it I'd like to
come back to if I could to something Jim
said I think this is a situation where
the tools and the technology and its
deployment are likely to continue to
change they'll be changing quickly but
they seem likely to change for a while
and I wonder if we disagree about this
or not because I know you're really
concerned about scale-up and and the
threats to many different parts of the
world derived from this but be my hope
that we could put in place a robust
framework supporting discussion and
perhaps partnership on topics and do you
think that's possible or do you think
that some of these issues around
cellulosic biofuels or other things are
going to trigger such powerful responses
from the civil society community if you
will that that we really only have a
very very small window of time and won't
be able to do anything beyond that so my
sense is that well what I see it's
coming from civil society
is that there's not a rational process
of saying that not that everyone
necessarily is here's a emerging
technology we need to make sure that we
have a sensible discussion around it
before we move it into society and
here's the process by which we're going
to do it and then we'll decide how to
move it into society which would be a
sensible way to go about it instead we
have his apart for technology we're
going to diffuse it as widely as
possible and wouldn't it be great to
have a discussion once it's out there
and that's that's entirely the wrong way
around and the the red flags for us of
seeing BP partnering with Synthetic
Genomics Chevron partnering with
Solazyme the largest sugar manufacturer
in Brazil partnering with amorous and
that this is no longer being driven by
those eight hundred and fifty people who
came to the iGEM competition it's being
driven by people in the boardrooms of
some of the most powerful corporations
on the planet and and that's that's the
worry there's no interested discussion
for those people Jim it strikes me
there's more discussion going on as this
technology is being developed than most
cell phones weren't really discussed
until they were suddenly in our hand
changing their lives
birth control pills weren't really
discussed until they were out there
changing all the humans behave genetic
engineering and food crops wasn't
discussed much until we're out there to
be dealt with
so compared to those at least this seems
like no indeed that's not discussion
than technology but at least the
discussion of the technology shouldn't
be emerging somewhat in parallel that
said my experience here I'm mostly
watching the motions of technology for
last two or three years is that that
isn't there isn't much of a discussion
around it and this is a great this is
great that there's beginning to be one
here
and you know quite frankly I want to
flip that round so that we're not
chasing and trying to catch up with our
technologies technologies are waiting
for our discussions that would be a sane
way to deal with innovation because this
isn't just about synthetic biology is
about all the different converging
technologies that are also happening at
the same time and that where we're being
beginning to feel bit in undeterred with
rather powerful disruptive technology
this is this sort of raises a point that
one here's some various places switches
biotechnology is zooming ahead right
down at the hundred nanometer scale
information technology is zooming ahead
of Moore's law pace at the nano 100
nanometer scale and nanotechnology such
as it is is zooming along somewhat coat
tailing on biotech but go ahead at some
point they're all accelerating each
other each one of them is auto catalytic
accelerating itself in combination they
seem to be accelerating each other how
does that play out in all this I mean
you're basically talking about
programming organisms true so this is
already an information technology story
if you understand DNA sequencing and DNA
synthesis technology the most
significant thing to take away from
those two in partnership is it makes
genetic material and genetic information
interconvertible right right so you can
imagine a future where you have the
itunes equivalent so it's not bits to
atoms anymore it's bits to really so so
so there's two things I'm freaked out
about one is how do we pay for this and
buy pay for this I mean energy and
widths all here come back for his talk
in january saul griffith and the long
now talk then i think we're gonna run
into a big constraint there and you know
sure these things might all be moving
along info nano bio but if we can't
afford the energy to drive it we're not
going anywhere
the second thing that I'm freaked out
about if you if you really crock this
this technology basically what it lets
you do is is change how nature
propagates over time and this is
something to think about over centuries
and millennia right now all of life is
one generation to the next and it's
constrained by a very powerful process
that includes replication with error so
sort of direct descent from one organism
to the next your parents to your
children to yourself to your children
and so on so direct descent and
replication with air provide huge
constraints I suspect on the
architecture of living systems if we can
sequence an organism figure it out
change it recompile it back down we
basically have a new alternate path
forward in time for propagating life
where this intermediate step requires us
to take direct responsibility for it and
what we've seen with genetic engineering
what we're seeing with synthetic biology
is the beginnings of the very sound like
big conversations now but I suspect
they're very small beginnings to a much
bigger conversation having to do with
how do we take direct responsibility for
the intentional manipulation or editing
or engineering choose the words you like
of genetic material and can we do that
so so I'll believe in the singularity
when somebody explains to me how we can
how we can pay for it with energy don't
see it you want all these organisms
signed yeah how does that work you sign
them you write down your name and DNA
print it there it is and oh and it goes
out there and does bad things one will
know where it came from and go Neil I'm
like who the anthrax tracked down well
that had its own issues but the the
signing of something into DNA needs to
be complemented with another thing which
is the publishing of that sequence
information in a different form right
onto a website right so if I have a DNA
signature and I'm signing all my DNA did
it it uh you could spoof my signature
and then I'll get in trouble right for
what came out so I need to not only sign
my DNA but they I need to make public I
need to disclose everything I'm
engineering everything I'm making I'd
like there's a watermark equivalents
they even a sure Wow I mean there's a
third part to that you also need a
liability regime so that if something
goes wrong well you're responsible for
something people can come back in there
yeah I'm thinking you for it my sense is
that's probably there already but I
don't know but you know maybe maybe yeah
there's been a very strongly
particularly by the US government to to
forestall that around genetically
modified organisms and my sense is the
industry would do its best
well we could probably put it in for
genetically engineered organisms yeah
crispy there's one player that not it's
not here
we should have a somebody from Amherst
er somebody who is basically taking a
commercial viewpoint on synthetic
biology because in a very interesting
way you seem to be supporting his open
source approach to this technology now
that has an interesting history because
with genetic engineering in food crops
which you've been paying attention to
and etc has been paying attention to
green pieces of paying attention to one
of the reasons that domain became
somewhat contained is because it got so
commercialized so very early and
pathless got locked up and the
Monsanto's and Syngenta's and so on
became very supportive of strong
regulations because that would help keep
the riff raff competition out of the
game which it did and it sort of locked
up the technology is really only two
major versions of genetically modified
food crops out there one for pests a
pesticide and another one and basically
an herbicide and then making millions
and it's the most controllable version
of biotech that we've had it's been no
military application I know yeah and it
seems like somebody who wants to keep a
lid on these technologies would say
commercialize it fast put in as few
corporations as possible lock up the IP
slow everything down and then we can
figure out what's going on well I mean
just to go to the GMO example you can
say that it's slowed down it hasn't
really done much you've only had a
couple of different varieties that ever
got anywhere it's been a very
unsuccessful experiment and a very
expensive one this is probably the first
year that the biotech industry has made
any kind of profit after what 30 years
that said it's also been tremendously
successful when when Monsanto and
Syngenta which was then ciba-geigy and
Santos started getting into the the GMO
business and buying up seed companies
there were thousands of small seed
companies there was a very diverse
agricultural market and and a lot of
that breeding was being done by by
public institutions what they were able
to do by deploying GMOs was was
concentrate that so we now have
basically four or five companies that
control almost the entire seed industry
and the
right industry and the fertilizer
industry get control over the market and
managed to convince the public breeders
that they had no place really in
developing this technology because it
was too costly and too expensive and so
they got out of developing plants and so
as a result those companies like
Monsanto Syngenta can pretty much walk
away from GMOs haven't succeeded exactly
what they wanted to get domination of
the marketplace and domination over the
entire food chain so technologically
you're right it wasn't a great success
in terms of power and commerce it was a
tremendous success and I think that's
what we're gonna see here with synthetic
biology whether or not it works or not
if this is the strategy by which a few
large players gain control over that
seventy six percent of the world's
biomass and either there may only be one
or two applications they're probably
going to be in fuels and plastics and
chemicals and if they nonetheless can
modify all of that which is currently
outside of the commercial system and
then it's a great success for them drew
what lessons do you draw from their
simple genetic engineering and food
crafts experience
I think that the rollout of stuff into
the environment needs to be to come back
to what we were just talking about more
vigorous disclosure what's happening I
find it to be amazing growing up in this
world that it's very difficult to pay
attention to know of the experiments to
know of the data to figure out if some
of the things I hear our fantasies are
true or what have you so I'd like to see
from that past experience a recognition
that we could do a lot better and in
part I think some of the tools we've got
would help with that I think it's
interesting to see the back and forth
between the commercial commercial
efforts and the civil society
organizations and how that's led to a
collapse of dialogue practically and I
find myself sitting here celebrating a
remarkable event but having it be a
one-off in my experience and wondering
why I grow up in a vacuum of dialog
around these issues if I could come back
to them and you just said you know who's
missing here is amorous oh the
commercial companies actually also who's
missing here's who's going to be
impacted it's the it's the farmers in
East Africa it's the workers in Brazil
who are gonna grow the sugarcane for
amorous all of those are missing and
it's gonna be a dialogue it has to
involve those people and you know one
proposal we could have is we could you
know yourself people from amorous those
people from Brazil we could we could
meet up and we could travel around visit
some of those places where the impacts
really going to be in and then we'll
come back and here's time and tell you
what we think I like the road trip
proposal yeah and I'd love to see you
know get Jim and some people from
Greenpeace at the bench of working with
BioBricks just get some experience with
him come to the gem chamber you see what
they bring and of what would you brand
what if you could fabricate in his world
yeah something cool that would be
absolutely in line with what etcetera
wants to have happen in the world what
would be the nifty but little synthetic
biology fool you'd like survey well I'd
fabricate a social technology I don't
think I've fabricated biological
technology and it would be a social
technology which allows large numbers of
people from diverse viewpoints to
collaboratively and participative Lee
that's new technologies and we could
bring that to a jam and we could we
could you know bring in different
viewpoints from around the world from
different knowledge systems to assess
these these different gizmos and if you
have a different two sets of judges yeah
the next item one is the ones who are
you know winning best environmental
project mostly in best presentation all
that kind of stuff and then this other
set of saying scariest project most
potentially deleterious most carelessly
contained and would likely follow so
judging is a real challenge if anybody
here would like to help judge please let
me know seriously I wouldn't necessarily
want to take a beautiful framework like
that and then force people to use
pejoratives and and and awards so yeah
okay here's a when you get two versions
of a question you know it's a real
question both the Eliza looks like
cooter and Richard me had the same
question this is for Jim I use Eliza's
version putting an industry of people
out of work could have been an argument
against all technology all machines
computers etc why is biotechnology
different or are you saying that all
technology is bad for putting poor
people out of jobs well it's not arguing
against all technology because you know
their technology technology z' that have
been the create work but certainly it's
true that if you look back over the
history of the last few waves of
technology you see a parallel where you
know we hear about those who ride the
wave who profit by it and so forth but
there's always usually the poor the
marginalized fewer who are disrupted by
the way if you're upset by it and I
think that's that's a lesson from
history that we should try and actively
bring in to how we assess technologies
the truth is we don't have any good
framework for controlling the social
impacts of innovation and it's a big
huge black hole that if there is a new
chief technology officer to be appointed
by the next president that's something
they should think about putting in place
they kind of had it the beginnings of it
with the office
technology assessment we probably need a
people's office of Technology Assessment
say yeah oh it's a question in a way for
both you probably start with Jim David
Harris hey this is on safety doesn't
horizontal gene transfer already create
vast numbers of new species quote that
are apparently harmless and this is sort
of the continuum between microbes who
have run the world they make the
atmosphere they eat our food they do all
and stuff and they're making a very new
wildly different versions of himself
every how often do they reproduce and
change depends where they're live in 20
minutes too much longer 20 minutes too
much longer so they're releasing new
species you know the biosphere all the
time is that qualitatively different
from what we're talking about here and
so the assumption I think that underlies
that question is that those species are
somehow random or that you know III
don't know I don't know the process by
which by which microbial communities
sort through those mutations and choose
amongst those mutations which ones are
are able to propagate and which ones
disappear it's I think it's probably a
very complex process and there are
others microbial ecologists you could
answer it far better what I do know is
that when amorous biotechnology or craig
Venter or whoever decides that they make
a new genome they then will mass produce
large quantities of it in industrial
sized quantities of it and and use that
an industrial setting and that's not
just one example of a new microbe coming
in and having to interact with a whole
microbial community that's a sort of a
brute force attack of that one single
species when we use that word and that
send me the problem with GM crops you
know that question came up with GM crops
well surely horizontal gene transfer
occurs what's the problem about
transferring and the difference is that
Monsanto doesn't transfer it once in one
seed we could probably mitigate against
that it then replicates that over
millions upon millions
affect us so a question I have that is
do we have examples from the 30 years of
since we're common in DNA of tailored
organisms getting loose in the wild and
doing whatever they do once they're out
there I could respond a little bit and
this isn't quite your question but I
think it's it's germane you know they're
a very good experience of a genetically
modified organism but that was stopped
luckily but could have caused a real
problem was there was a Klebsiella plant
Accola it's a bacterium which was
modified in order to turn wheat stalks
into ethanol and the idea was this would
be a way of using exactly as being
proposed now and cellulosic material and
turn into ethanol and a very good soil
microbiologist at the University of
Oregon and Laningham checked to see what
would happen if that was released into
the soil as slurry and waste and founder
of course it would have turned a lot of
the material in the soil into ethanol
which would have killed off the soil now
that was stopped but this is exactly the
sort of things that we're seeing
proposed with synthetic biology we're
looking at microbes that will turn
cellulosic material into gasoline or jet
fuel or plastics so there's an example
from genetic modification but isn't the
fact that it was stopped an example of a
successful safety framework well I think
that was extremely lucky it was that
there was a laning I'm sort and thought
to change it
there aren't many usually don't do a
screen against the effect on so soil
microbiology new GM organisms well so
fair enough but it was stopped and there
are many other things that can be done
and are done to try and reduce the
impact of the if you say unfair
advantage an engineered organism has
relative to its natural counterparts
which is that it can be amplified
greatly and deployed in the environment
at scale it's interesting and I think
some of this certainly has to be
validated in the laboratory first it's
interesting to think about what you can
do with synthetic
approaches so if you're redesigning a
genome it's actually possible to recode
the entire genetic table how DNA is read
out into proteins and it seems
conceivable that you could invent a new
genetic code for which every point
mutation every point mutation would be
deleterious so that if your genetic code
changed at all
it would stop the organism from
continuing you'd have what an engineer
would call a fail fast genetic code this
would require changing the genetic code
from a triplet code to a quadruplet code
and so on I mean it's a huge set of
modifications if you look back at the
history of genetic engineering the
conversation south of here at Asilomar
where they were thinking about
recombinant DNA and biosafety focused in
part on how do we engineer the bacteria
that we're engineering so that they
themselves are safer and it's not
perfect I'll grant you that and there is
a big amplifier associated with taking
something out and releasing it another
lesson from genetic modification if you
will in the conversations around that is
how safety and control are oftentimes
coupled so what was branded or labeled
Terminator technology that controls the
propagation of a plant his organization
named yeah I'm giving him credit
you know also created a subscription
dependency with respect to economic
models as I understand it for access to
the so engineered seeds all right so do
you like it because it doesn't propagate
and maybe you know or or you upset about
it because it forces people to continue
paying fees every year you know how do
we how do we how do we balance stuff
like that there's a question for your
drill as I understand you guys are up to
intelligent design you want to take this
totally Cluj apparatus that biology has
brought us after 3.5 billion years of
screwing around and everything you know
total Cluj of patches and layers and
moronic leftovers and pieces of virus
that are just baggage at this point
you're gonna take that and i understand
the term is refactoring
into you want to build it because it was
so unbelievable to build a workable non
mess and this is a great Frankenstein
dr. Frankenstein moment you're not
playing God you're playing you're not
playing nature either I'm an engineer
you're playing intelligent design God
but we keep saying doesn't exist well so
really intelligent design would have
documentation that that explains Who I
am and that's part of your goal right
yeah but it comes back to you know if
you look at our first naive initial
attempt at refactoring a genome the
modifications we made and we made 600 of
them at once resulted in a new organism
encoding the same proteins as the
natural isolate but its ability to
reproduce itself was knocked down by
about 40 percent or 50 percent so from
an environmental perspective it's much
less fit it only survives in our
laboratory setting because we devote
tremendous amounts of resources to
keeping it at in existence we create an
artificial selection if you will I could
look forward to a day where we can
refactor natural living organisms and we
understand them and we know how to put
the pieces back together and we don't
lose the beauty and magic and fitness of
life but we're very far away from doing
that
there's one example that concerns me as
I was trained as an ecologist Yemen
frankly I'm not so worried about the
genetically modified crops so far but
we've got climate change coming on and
adaptation has to occur and especially
places in Africa and in the tropics
generally are very fragile and they are
going to get drier and they're going to
get saltier and they're gonna get more
floods and so there's work very good
work now on flood tolerant rice coming
out of UC Davis which is being field
tested now and
can fabulously there's going to be all
sorts of drought-tolerant food plants
corn and sorghum and whatnot coming
along ecological question there is
usually food crops have no chance once
they get over the fence into the jungle
it's a jungle out there and yeah their
talents don't work
they only work in the special place
where there's lots of water and all that
but if you make really good salt
tolerant and drought tolerant plants
they're gonna be dealing with an
impoverished native population around
them because most plants can't handle
the salt I can't handle drought and so
do you think there's going to be an
issue of this being a case where finally
an engineered organism is actually
better at being an a version of the wild
than the things that already live there
and should we worry about this I think
it was useful what drew showed in one of
his pictures the the image of a corn you
know as a as a which is an engineered
plant it's engineered by thousands of
generations of Mexican campesinos and
that in fact many of the these salt
tolerant drought tolerant stress
resistant genes that are being so-called
discovered at Davis and elsewhere I know
they're not being invented there they're
being found actually in life foods that
have been developed over generations by
farmers and in fact you know farmers in
in the South in the developing world I
have a long history of developing
varieties that resist change climate
change and other changes and they do
this by having many different varieties
and and hedging against them and I think
it's actually extremely arrogant to
think that UC Davis has come up with
something that actually was really
developed by the wisdom and knowledge of
thousands of farmers beforehand what
worries me and what we're seeing now is
that those climate genes or whatever are
being patented you know so BASF and
Monsanto were putting literally
thousands of passive our summer without
rice one isn't well that one might not
be but many are and and Submarine
patterns that go across a you know a
whole range of different crops
and they will get deployed as
monocultures and as sort of Silver
Bullet solutions whether it's Africa's
problems or Southeast Asia which will
eradicate some of the more subtle and
diverse breeding strategies the farmers
left to their own devices would would
employ and that would work just as well
of course if they had their own
biotechnology they don't locally by
technology they'll be around races but
they do have their own biotech knowledge
it's been around for thousands of years
and these are breeding strategies and
they're very complex knowledge systems
and I think then there needs to be a
recognition certainly by those
responsible for food and agriculture
that those complex breeding systems
bye-bye indigenous and local communities
are as as as knowledge-based as
biotechnology or synthetic biology so
this strikes me is the major overlap
actually between you guys is you both
are very strong for it empowering
grassroots yeah and the difference is
pace your technology is moving pretty
quickly and you worry about the speed is
that right I'm worried anin particularly
worried actually about how it encroaches
upon the existing encroaches on existing
grassroots technologies such as breeding
when we talked earlier and I proposed
that the precautionary principle which
has been you know Kevin Kelly has a
different version via max more a lot the
pro action area principle and there's
you know a whole bunch of things I think
people are really upset about the
precautionary principle because it seems
to stop things and not take risk
balancing seriously and so on so my big
proposal is keep the precautionary
principle and add the vigilance
principle the vigil mist principle being
eternal vigilance is the price of
Liberty as originally said about
defending against slavery an
abolitionist in Boston over 100 years
ago and it then focuses on what's
actually happening in the world rather
than what do we imagine bad things that
might occur in the world because there's
also an infinity of bad things that we
can imagine and a very limited number
than of good things that we can imagine
Golden Rice is going to keep kids from
going blind in large parts of the rice
eating world and then other people say
no if they have that kind of rice they
would eat their vegetables or
corporations will take it over or they
won't like it because it's golden
instead of why all these worries come up
and the crushin says we can imagine
these worries therefore either don't do
it or let us control it or do it very
slowly but a vigilance would say okay
someone's out there probably we need to
know where it is what it's doing and do
we care and what are the surprise that
sort of in surprises
applause cell phones empowered poor
people all over the world what are the
bad surprises and it can they be
corrected now part of what I get from
both of you having this grassroots
approach is that this is empowering a
lot of people to pay attention in a
distributed way like Wikipedia or
something to what's actually going on
and having the knowledge that you would
impart from the social civil standpoint
and you would impart from the
engineering standpoint the people know
when things are good or bad what's going
on they know how to find a signature in
a piece of peculiar DNA
is that a way to also link the approach
to both of your occasion sorry if we go
long reappear I I think that you see a
big challenge here and it's a challenge
in that there is this similarity around
openness and networks but it starts and
I'll say this in the abstract with an
asymmetry meaning I'm in a position
where I'm enabling an open network and
it's out of my control I mean it is out
of my control there's no illusion I can
have that I could tell everybody what
the IgM students are gonna do and that
they're safe I'm trying to promulgate
best practice and I'm building a
constructive culture and I'm trusting
that most human beings are optimistic
and constructive Jim and and I hope I
represent this fairly Jim represents a
different open community and he is a
node in the middle of that community me
he's here speaking for it representing
very diverse groups with great wisdom
and differences of opinions and
practical experiences and concerns and
what we don't see even with the rise of
the cellphone and all sorts of micro
financing and what-have-you
is we don't see the the thing that Jim
represents that hope in network matched
up to the network that is out of my
control that I'm somehow biasing a
snowball as it runs and it starts to run
and and so I think the challenge or the
gap if you will between us is is is
there a way via tools of communication
dialogue decision-making what have you
to map those two communities up or
actually have them be one community if
we could solve that problem that becomes
pretty interesting if we can't solve
that problem we default to lower energy
less interesting social solutions
cultural solutions societal solutions
how would you do that yeah I think
that's I think that's it's really nicely
put
and but there's also a thing that comes
to mind is there's also an asymmetry of
power yes you're enabling a number of
people to create something without
control but largely speaking they're
very powerful section of the global
community what I'm concerned about the
section of the global community that
generally have less power but who are
going to be impacted by any
technological change and this is going
to be a very big one and the viewpoint
that's likely to come from those with
less power who've dealt with being
disenfranchised again and again is you
stop you stop exercising that power and
privilege that you already have and then
we'll have a discussion and particularly
if you're going to be releasing
technologies that you don't quite know
how to recall then that's that becomes a
preconditioning for having that
discussion and uncommon way of working
together start
question for you Jim Molly's Pontiac
I'll try to think if I'm Barack Obama
yeah you're trying to put terms and
conditions on whether I would talk to
Iran I don't think you're wrong Iran is
low on power Jim you're one of the very
few who's paying attention in the
environmentalist world which is a huge
body of people by now and there's a kind
of a general knowledge and framing a lot
of environmental groups about genetic
engineering but that's a pretty sleepy
backwater up a biotech at this point and
it's focused kind of on the agro ecology
and so on which is great there's a lot
of people learning aggregate ecology and
that's always good learning about gene
flow insects are there's not so many as
near as I can tell you're the only one
I'm aware of and you wrote this book
this sort of pamphlet extreme genetic
engineering soar to make the connection
for that crowd to understand that it's
getting weirder out there are they
paying attention should they pay
attention should they be going into the
biotech labs and trying to find really
well-schooled biotech people who will
take on this putting the larger
framework around all of this so the
responsibility and accountability and
transparency follows every step of the
way is that happening at all or are you
having a generational gap in the
environmental movement what's going on
um it is happening a little bit and I
definitely need to happen a lot more and
as I mentioned three or four years ago
there was an open letter which we wrote
along with 37 other organizations
calling for the synthetic biology to
move away from voluntary or involuntary
oversight so there are others taking
taking notes and that's probably
increasing we just had a meeting here
in San Francisco where about 80 people
from different groups were meeting to
get up to speed on synthetic biology so
it is changing in a way it's not just
the environmentalist community the
people who really need to be engaged
with this so those who are looking at
human rights those who are looking at
development questions and the rights of
farmers and those are going to be
impacted and yeah we there's a there's
definitely a lack of capacity to assess
from those different points of view and
people have a lot of struggles the
world's going through a lot of
challenges and to look 5 10 15 years in
the future is really hard for those who
are struggling for their lives and
wonder if it's it's worth doing when you
have gatherings like that which are
clearly really needed to get word around
in a sense of focus and so on it sounds
like based on what we've seen here would
be worth having one or two people from
the world from the synthetic biology
world to take a day or two and come and
plus in and hold forth they're not going
to dominate the rap because they'll be
one out of 50 people or whatever it is
but it'd be nice to have them in the
room they may go away with their hair on
fire they may go away Chasen's no one
doesn't know likewise when the when the
syn bio nerds assemble I don't know if I
Jun was the right place but it does
happen there are conferences and
creeping it was the the syn bio
conference every year now what's it five
years old portal are there people from
Jin's world at those conferences yeah I
was there you were there
oh and drew it's just that a civil
society meeting we just had on synthetic
biology so that's the beginning of that
discussion so he was there record on was
he there the previous year yes at Zurich
okay so there's now a bit of continuity
and you've seen these guys growth they
probably doubled between those times but
they're still one of you yeah I may have
a lot more money in that pocket I met
quite pleased with what one wants is the
critics and questioners to be almost as
knowledgeable or as knowledgeable or
more knowledgeable than the
practitioners of these things is that a
hopeless cause I I don't I don't think
that's a fair way of framing a question
I think that in all of my experiences
with Jim and his colleagues there has
been a symmetry of learning that there
are lots of missteps and there's lots of
misunderstandings but there are many
interesting things being shared and you
know to think you know that in my own
existence I've never been south of the
Equator right to consider the impact of
what's happening around sugar production
and biofuels and listen to
representatives of indigenous
populations from the Philippines or
Brazil or learn that there might be
landless peasants in Brazil and so I
mean I'm just completely ignorant of
that and so one would hope that the
technologists and I don't think
technologists just work with wet stuff
for computer stuff for her or
what-have-you but you know there's
social technologists you know we can all
learn from one another and that's been
my my limited but privileged experience
where in the world is this is synthetic
biology moving quickly clearly here in
the u.s. is it happening in Europe is it
happening in Asia and after
Middle East Israel orders the action my
perspective the u.s. is farthest along
Europe with all respect to great
colleagues there tends to spend a lot of
time debating the definition of the
field Asia is in a way that's very
different from the US moving at a
national level in different countries in
ways that I would recognize as being
strategic Jim would recognize as being
terrifying
perhaps China is moving quickly in
genetic engineering food crops so now
are they doing the same in synthetic
biology I've heard reports but I've not
seen the output of those discussions and
what I've heard is from a technologists
perspective very impressive how about
India some representation with respect
to high gem but I'm not well aware
beyond that and the students that you're
seeing come from what backgrounds
anything right I think the the thing
that surprises me consistently around
synthetic biology is there is an
attraction to biology both as a science
to understand but also as a technology
platform for building if I think what
happened around the generational
transition in computing where all of a
sudden you got people building their own
computers in part that was because the
tools the technical tools came in place
but it's also because people are very
excited about the silicon based
competing technology my limited
experience biotechnology is way more
cool and so the students come from
engineering computer science English
mathematics you name it cultural
backgrounds they want to build stuff
culture of construction I mean I noticed
for example of the group at this year's
Jamboree who won the environmental
project prize was three students from
Brown who came up
they looked like a cheap bacterial test
for toxins in the water and one lady was
clearly Caucasian and looked like to me
like the other two were maybe Indian or
Bangladesh or anyway South Asia and as I
look at the teams it's a it's a pretty
rainbow group but that's true of all the
technologies these days I hope that's
true
III would rather look forward to the
diversity that Jim represents here and
and seeing that matched up right and
having something much more powerful or
improbable and beautiful come out as a
result yeah I just like to say I don't
represent that diversity and I'm really
aware of that one of the I don't
represent that diversity I'm very aware
of that and I'm a white male well
educated northern you know the elite
privileged person what needs to happen
in discussions like this is to actually
have those people speak for themselves
and that's what's missing well I'll send
with a question from Kevin Kelly it's
aimed at Jim but it's into both for you
what would your ideal synthetic biology
system look like when it is mature say
in 100 years closed in a laboratory and
with with no escapes into the biosphere
and entirely for the purpose of
understanding how the world works not
for trying to profit by it so it's for
investigative science only and it's only
in the lab yes
and I'd like to have the discussion with
with other with other groups about
whether that's something we move forward
there is if there is an artificial
malarek rule that's been developed which
is the artemisinin project in the that's
amorous is developing
however the assumptions there that there
isn't enough natural artemisinin
available or entirely wrong and in the
process it's going to undercut the
existing market for natural artemisinin
so i don't want to make assumptions that
these things exist in in you know that
there's a context and i want to make
sure that context is fully investigated
i want i want to have a really
participative and thorough discussion
that's the Saltine question so in
question my my hundred years out we've
solved the biosecurity situation by
practically taking emerging infectious
diseases whether they be natural or
otherwise produced off the table and
that requires huge worldwide cooperation
we have sufficient prowess with
biological engineering that if somebody
wanted to grow a tail so that if you're
soldering you could hold the two wires
and have a third thing for the soldering
iron that would be temporary or
permanent what you've got it you've got
it at your discretion
how about 10 years that's harder I think
you know you could look at some of the
trending technologies and one where
there's uncertainty but least relative
to others is construction of DNA as of
this month were a factor of 3,000 away
from being able to construct three Giga
bases of DNA which is a human genome
equivalent if you look at the pacing of
the sequencing projects that took six
years to go from a bacteria to a human
genome draft
I wonder where will be with respect to
just printing pieces of DNA in ten years
it could be a very different world in
terms of the parts and composition of
the parts and actually validating them
and having them act like Legos if that's
even possible
all bets are off ten years general I go
back to what I said for 100 years now
I'm thinking of them work having the
captain's challenge which is really
important the question of well you know
if there is a a cure which which can be
implemented surely you don't want to
stop that and I I I guess what I guess
what I'm the reason I'm kicking back
against that is I worry about the
suggestion that they're the answer to
health problems is always technological
and you know health is as much a
socially determined as it is by disease
and so forth so I would want to be just
sure that there isn't a better and there
isn't a better social response to
overcoming a cure that couldn't be
implemented more safely but if it was
agreed that there isn't then maybe I
would open up to open up the path
clearly we're gonna have a lot of
discussion for the next ten years the
next 100 years on this thank you for
joining this one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]